this is what would happen if you jumped
into a pool full of liquid mercury
liquid mercury is a shiny metal that's
constantly in a liquid state in theory
you could fill up a pool with it but
could you jump in and swim well not
exactly if you jumped in from a diving
board you'd be met with a thud rather
than a satisfying Splash that's because
Mercury is 13 times more dense than
water and substantially heavier and
walking into the pool would be like
standing on watery Jello that would be
incredibly difficult to balance on not
only that but the liquid mercury would
cause severe burns and irritation
wherever it touched your skin and the
longer you leave it on your skin the
worse it gets prolonged exposure to
liquid mercury would result in mercury
poisoning and over time this could
result in vision loss speech
difficulties and a lack of coordination
oh and also if you stayed in the pool
long enough you'd pass out from the
fumes and die so